hello welcome to this video playing FM
Volvo reen yeah and sort of the frequent
opponents and one of the opponent's way
I constantly have issues with this this
quick playing style playing super
committal moves quickly and so on anyway
let's see what happens here the anthesis
this already takes with the porno
probably and after Bishop 86 is in bad
shape or what is doing nope so rookie
one at which one this one not not sure
yeah I have a slight speed advantage Jim
who is taking time what is wrong with
you
hmm
the bishop interesting there should be
five is that side an issue I mean the D
file looks kind of looks dangerous I'm
already threatening Bishop d7 a9 f5
hmm that looks weird yep yep c5 was a
somewhat strange move you really should
think about the D foul him I actually be
that c5 already is a bit questionable
but ok so let's play it simple that wins
the Queen I guess let's think about this
though so i can take g7 now or queen g4
is also pretty pretty good yeah this is
the best move right it's made already g7
ng6 night h6 mate is some not a big
difference then Queen takes 27
yeah now he lets the clock run down kind
of yeah anyway we can do a bit of an
analysis here already had done to the
disconnects or whatever so I think see
five years a bit early opening up the
position when why does a little bit
better coordinated black resigns okay so
we can do a real analysis now let's go
back to this point i think it probably
should delay the move a little bit
quincy seven or something like that the
engine wants to go for guns to go see
fire but i don't like it okay yeah pawn
takes this Bishop a six and this should
be a slight edge for white because of
the hanging pawns getting weaker after
the bishops are traded where the d5 pawn
in particular and the light squares
should be a little bit better for right
now okay now I'm getting something in
the in the center but I think the real
issue is Bishop c5 I don't really see a
good move after Bishop b5 here my
engineer is why twins after Bishop b5
already I'm threatening 96 and we should
be seven that's a bit much maybe 95 but
yeah it's already lost and he has no
moves this is the engines move it's
funny
okay I'll hear the game at least
continues for a little bit guarantee
it's just over I expected tweenty one
try to hang on but check and this is
what I'm going to play takes I know
objects and Queen g4 it's still an
attack that's a problem yeah TM it's
made in a couple the engine shows the
way to delay it check it little bit now
checkmate it's made on g7 so there was a
quick win okay well thanks for watching